I have chronic line with a right machine be a good investment so anybody who's
following me knows that that's probably big piece of person big reason why a
person would follow me is they're interested in right technology because we've
been using right technology for gosh 20 some years now 25 years 25 years
yes yes 25 years will stand up wow there's somebody thought of that so but so
no a right for sheet who for those who don't know what that is is a great
light frequency generator and it's used to stimulate the body at different
frequencies what's the best so again any therapy tool is just that it's a tool
and any tool needs to be used correctly you could use a screwdriver to hammer
a nail in but it's not going to be very effective you could use a hammer to
hammer it a screw but you lost the benefit of the screw now you just use it as a nail
so you want to use a tool correctly let's say my main issue was heavy metal
toxicity that was my main issue nobody just has one problem right so when I buy
a right machine to help me detox heavy metals well yeah there's benefits to a
right machine to help you detox because you can run liver frequencies you can run
you know detox protocols of different things with the right machine but I would do
other things maybe even you know more so before I would invest in a right
for sheet or my heavy metal toxicity but if I have a live disease if I have
cancer if I have a chronic infection which ties to many many autoimmune diseases
definitely a right for sheet is a good investment so right for sheet uses light
frequencies to help your body kill different things so it can help your body
kill cancer it can help your body kill Lyme disease which is Borrelia,
Bartonella and other colon infections that go with Lyme can help chronic viruses we
used Lyme a lot at this last quote-unquote pandemic it was it can be very
beneficial to help protect your family it's a great tool you feel like you're
coming down with something it's I think I think everybody would be
benefited to have a right for sheet in their home but if I had an issue like
cancer or a chronic Lyme disease absolutely you should have a right in your
home it's you know with chronic Lyme the difficulty is most chronic Lyme moves to
what I call phase three which is an autoimmune phase so once you're at an
autoimmune phase you already have your body has made antibodies against
self-tissue and once your body makes antibodies against self-tissue now you have
now you have a bigger problem because you can't kill an infection using normal
leads that a person would want to kill an infection from a national perspective so
if I have an infection I would take certain nutrients certain herbs let's say I
take a combination of garlic to kill this infection that I have feel like I have
this long infection coming on I take our combination garlic and maybe I would
take some different mushrooms quarter saps is really good for the lungs to help
kill this lung infection and it knocks the lung infection out well a chronic
infection like Lyme which is a chronic infection not acute infection if it
leads to your making your body immune system making antibodies against self-tissue
and you take things that will stimulate the immune response you could actually
make yourself worse because you'll kill that what you have antibodies against
first which is self-tissue so you're gonna kill self-tissue by stimulating the
immune system by taking a combination or like a cat's claw things like that
things that you normally used to help kill Lyme you've got to be careful it
consuming those things well how do you kill a chronic infection if you can't take
immune stimulants to kill a chronic infection well that's where the rifa-sheet
shines so rifa-sheet isn't using immune stimulants rifa-sheet isn't
stimulating your immune system a rifa-sheet program correctly for chronic
Lyme is is killing directly so then you're not killing self-tissue you're not
stimulated your immune system to kill self-tissue let's have antibodies to
your thyroid so you have Hashimoto's maybe produced by the live disease maybe
produced from something else plus you have a chronic infection and you take a
bunch of immune stimulants to try to kill the chronic infection you're gonna
make your Hashimoto's much worse you're gonna kill you're gonna damage the
thyroid glad you're gonna kill thyroid cells you could end up in a hyper
thyroid issue with a gravestis disease you could end up with just greater Hashimoto
symptoms unable to get that under control what it's been under control for a
number of years all sorts of problems can come up so a rifa-sheet doesn't do
that right but she's gonna kill directly you're doing so it's not gonna kill
your self-tissue it's not gonna stimulate an immune response then it's gonna
get her right damage to self-tissue if you have self-tissue antibodies so long
answer to I have Lyme chronic Lyme would a rifa-sheet be a good
best fit but the answer is yes